all right well then last but certainly
not least let's go over uh connor's
final one
which is hitosuma okay hold up before
you say anything
all right i the animation on this is
probably the worst i've seen in a long
time it's pretty bad but god damn
all these [ __ ] stories hot as [ __ ]
not gonna lie though man the one thing
that just
i mean look first of all i'm personally
not that huge into milfs but i can
appreciate like a good north when i see
one right there are some hot milks in
this one
right but not gonna lie that second guy
that came up
kind of looks like you no
no he looks like you no he doesn't i
looked at that i'm like
[ __ ] off this way is this what connor
likes this is like
it's like an easy self-insertion that
had never occurred to me i did not think
that guy looked anything
like like look it up like i don't know
like i'll put up a picture but like
i don't know out of all the hentai
characters that i've seen this one looks
the most like you
[ __ ] off yeah no it doesn't don't i
don't remember this one
it's like he's like kind of like lightly
like ashy blonde uh no
he doesn't look same haircut as you no
he doesn't yeah no he doesn't
out of every hand out of all the hints
i've seen he looks the most like you all
right so hot or not jerry
it's okay which means okay give me the
pluses and minuses obviously the
animation it's queen b okay yeah it's
queen b
again okay the main mum with the short
hair hot
yeah i i there's something about
short-haired milfs i really like
yes yeah nice i mean like i said this i
don't have much to say about this that i
haven't already said because i feel like
i would just be repeating myself it's
queen bee cool premise great character
designs
do this have you watched any of the
other episodes of this hentai no
there's one there's one it's like
episode four
and it's like a one shot right and like
the premise is that like the mom
who's sitting in the room uh her
daughter the boyfriend comes over
and is like oh mom i'm sorry but uh it
i i'm really sorry and i feel bad but uh
my dick won't fit in your daughter
and she's like oh oh okay and then he
goes can you please take a look at it
and tell me if there's anything wrong
with it
and then obviously you know he gets it
out yeah and then he's
she's like she's like oh god oh god oh
no she's like i think you should
hold it so you can feel it better but
he's playing innocent the whole time
right
i think you should like suck it as well
and then it's like oh my god
i couldn't [ __ ] get over the [ __ ]
bulges of the gym instructors though in
the first one i'm like
oh yeah i'm like i'm like is that a
penis or are you like smuggling a
chihuahua
i don't know because that is you might
as well not be wearing pants yeah
episode two sucks for this but episode
one's good dude i think it's hard man i
love it i mean yeah
like i said it's it's very you it's very
the story is amazing it's
very connor i would say like i i i think
the other
the other queen of the anime was better
i think ntr is just hot man i don't know
why
i'm saying nts hot in hentai no
no no
you are against rape but you're okay
with ncr wait
ntr is cheating right no and ntr
is when um there's like you have you
have like a couple that have like a
relationship or something right
and like the guy likes the girl and the
guy sees the girl
get [ __ ] oh i thought i thought ngo
was just uh for some reason there's so
much like a different kind of cheating
no that's like no no
there was a tag for cheating yeah
cheating's hot and hentai there's
there's this i mean i'm gonna get [ __ ] i
don't know about that
despite i get cheating in real life
obviously it's [ __ ] up don't do it
wrong
in porn it's not hurting anyone yeah
pretty sure me and joey can't say that
yeah we can't say anything
but no no because ntr in a relationship
you can't say that
cheating in porn is hot no i don't like
it no no
oh man yeah i mean personally like
cheating is just kind of like the same
as ntr for me
yeah where it's it's like you're okay i
don't like antioxidants
ncr is a step above where you're
watching this guy [ __ ] get
emotionally and like destroyed
you're seeing his like life get
destroyed like that and that was like
really [ __ ]
weird and it was like he this guy had
videos of his wife [ __ ] someone
and it was yeah oh yeah i think i'm
honestly [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah yeah
and the difference in ntr and cheating
is that if the guy's there or not yeah
yeah i don't want to see the guy
yeah i don't want i don't want to know
he's a real person yeah the
ncr is cheating but the guy's there and
she's [ __ ] crying
the reason why somehow he has a hard-on
yeah because i guess some people like
why is that
because some people like to get cucked i
guess is that just so much into our hint
of guys like
he's having a cry because in that inner
headset i think they all have like
husbands right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's like
because you don't see them so i if i saw
them i'd feel like
yeah yeah yeah yeah if i saw their
husbands and they did like a quick
hey here's jerry it's sheila's husband
i'd be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] no don't tell me that right because
they don't exist in my mind yeah and boy
but but in this one you do see the
husband
do you yeah i don't remember that it's
because like the at the beginning
right the the short head they dropped
them off yeah yeah no no it's
uh the short-haired girl gets invited to
join the dance club right yeah and then
she tells her husband like hey is it
okay if i go to it and the husband's
like yeah go for it
yeah but it's just hot seeing them be
like [ __ ] i'm really horny but i
shouldn't
the one thing that i couldn't [ __ ]
get over is the fact that like and i
think this is just a me problem but like
the guy the short head mom how she like
finally comes over the fact that like
i'm about to get [ __ ] by this gym
instructor yeah yeah i don't know why
but the gym instructor
his voice he's like reminds me of like
an esports commentator
he's just like so ducky yeah he's just
like okay
so we're going to uh pull the pants down
and insert the penis
in japanese yeah that's the japanese
equivalent like japanese equivalents
like can you feel the penis it's
entering you right now oh look at that i
think i think hentai is almost more
enjoyable
because i don't understand i
he was literally [ __ ] this girl and
he was like a play-by-play yeah
like there could have been a [ __ ]
color commentary like on the next
how does it feel to have my dig inside
of you okay i'm gonna move slowly now
it's like it's just just [ __ ] her just
fine
i just thought the scene was really hot
when the the woman the one the black one
was just like
yeah you see if you could join the club
or not oh the instructor that looks like
you
that's why i couldn't get over it i'm
just like this is hilarious because i
was trying to think of hentai that i
like
could like look back at and be like okay
yeah i normally yeah this is fine
and that was only one of them because a
lot of them i just forget yeah the thing
i do the thing i didn't like about this
is the group sex i i don't like group
sex man
it's it's it's hit or miss with me it's
it's a hit or miss for me as well like
it's like gangbang it's a hit or miss
for me sometimes if it's done well it's
good no because
i mean groups is peaceful gang banging
groups
group sex is just gangbang but just with
extra girls you know
it's it's tasteful it's gang banging
with
organizations i'll tell you what groups
like group sex is just vanilla gangbang
it's just it's just groom's actually
just for people who are just like no
gangbang that's that's that's got too
much space organized
i like that it's very orderly everyone's
partners are designated yeah he's like
choose a partner everybody all right off
you go do your own thing
okay group sex is just gang man with a
schedule yeah you know what i mean it's
it's this this
i like schedules so it's it's nice it's
nice and managed but you know at the
same time
you know like i don't know like we're
talking about stealth and sir i don't i
don't want to [ __ ]
girls in front of other dudes you know
what i mean especially if those dudes
especially if you know those dudes
that's that's uh oh my god that's that's
a little bit
i don't know i don't particularly
but yeah the thing i did like about this
was you know obviously the character
designs i like it when
okay i like it when the milfs have pubes
i don't know some something about
something about anime yeah it's
realistic something about anime vaginas
when you you they take
they take off their [ __ ] pants and
you see like their smooth ass vagina
that's been like that's
like that's look that looks like it's
been put through a [ __ ] car buffer
you know what i mean that's like the
biggest [ __ ] turn off for me man i
don't know
like i like i like it especially
especially with the
mature girls yeah yeah well that's what
i was about to say like if if it's like
if it's like milfs then like
without pubes it just looks [ __ ]
weird but every other time like i don't
mind either way
but with milfs it's like no you need pew
yeah when i when i see like the sights
on my head
shine but on like a [ __ ] vagina i'm
like that shouldn't be shining there man
that's a place that should not be
shining someone just got laser surgery